this event is put on by the vegas
chamber the theme this year is battle
reborn as the las vegas economy comes
back from the pandemic at the vegas
chambers preview las vegas event
governor steve sisilak said about 11 000
new jobs are coming in the next few
years in manufacturing ev companies and
distribution facilities some new things
coming into the state coming into
southern nevada despite the omicron wave
the governor projects southern nevada's
economic future will be a bright one i
don't plan on having to take any steps
backwards we're moving forward in the
fight against covet and omicron right
now and we're going to continue to move
forward we're working on economic
diversification in bringing new and
emerging industries here to southern
nevada the las vegas economy will also
benefit from hosting major events like
the nfl draft and the super bowl prices
are not expected to drop anytime soon
though inflation is a big challenge for
our small businesses especially as the
price of goods increases and then
another thing that our small businesses
are having trouble with is the talent
pool these are all challenges that we at
the vegas chamber are working to help
them overcome the vegas chambers said it
was a pretty big deal for them to be
able to host this event inside a legion
stadium the governor noted it's a place
that opened during the darkest days of
the pandemic hector mejia reporting live
local now